Buenos días y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en France 24 para esta
entrevista exclusiva con Santiago Peña
candidato a la presidencia de Paraguay
para el partido Colorado señor Peña
Muchísimas gracias por recibirnos en su
casa y hacernos un hueco en esta agenda
no durante la campaña electoral un
placer Valeria mucho gusto de conocerte
compartir acá contigo y bueno con toda
la audiencia de France Me gustaría saber
en caso de que usted gane las elecciones
el próximo 30 de abril cuáles son sus
primeras medidas o sea Cuáles son las
necesidades hoy de Paraguay según su
visión Paraguay necesita acelerar su
proceso de modernización del Estado
Paraguay ha avanzado en algunas áreas
principalmente en el manejo
macroeconómico un Banco Central
independiente un Ministerio de Hacienda
con una política fiscal de largo plazo
pero necesita acelerar principalmente en
el ámbito del capital humano la
formación del capital humano
la salud la educación eje centrales de
los cambios que queremos hacer en los
próximos años y un elemento central que
creo que es la mejor política social que
puede tener un país que es la generación
de empleo Paraguay tiene una población
joven una población que hoy tiene
aspiraciones tiene sueños anhelos y creo
que la generación de empleo y Paraguay
está en una posición geográfica
envidiable en el corazón de Sudamérica Y
con esa estabilidad macroeconómica tiene
que construir otro tipo de política que
generen el fomento de la inversión pero
así mismo la generación de empleo y qué
hacer con el tema de la salud pública
porque ha habido incluso un debate en
las últimas semanas sobre una
posibilidad de privatizar cuál es su
posición no la privatización nunca fue
una propuesta La idea es modernizar el
sistema de prestación como lo han hecho
países como Uruguay verdad a mí me tocó
ir a trabajar a mirar el modelo de
Uruguay y Uruguay estaba hace 15 años en
el mismo lugar que estamos hoy nosotros
y qué hizo Uruguay en los últimos 15 lo
que hizo fue el estado empezó a
preocuparse más en la prestación de la
salud pública y la prestación pública la
puede hacer una institución pública o la
puede hacer una institución privada pero
el servicio siempre un servicio público
pagado por el estado el Paraguay es un
país geográficamente muy grande parece
en el mapa un país pequeño pues más
grande que Alemania para una población
pequeña entonces la entrega de servicios
públicos se hace cada vez más difícil
para una población dispersa y ahí donde
tiene que entrar el trabajo entre el
sector público y el sector privado donde
el la responsabilidad del estado es la
prestación el estado tiene que asegurar
que tanto un ciudadano en la capital
como en el interior tenga la misma
calidad atención médica señores Se ganó
las elecciones internas del partido
Colorado con el apoyo de Horacio cartes
que está sufriendo
unas sanciones del gobierno de los
Estados Unidos Incluso se habla de una
posible hipotética extradición a usted
no le preocupa la sombra de cartes para
su credibilidad internacional No para
nada Horacio Carter es presidente del
partido Colorado fue electo por mandato
popular por una gran mayoría y una gran
diferencia de las elecciones el 18 de
diciembre es un caso emblemático porque
nunca antes en la historia del Paraguay
se dio que un expresidente de la
República siga teniendo una adhesión
popular tan grande como la que tiene él
y obviamente tiene también una
responsabilidad empresarial es un gran
empresario y tiene sus abogados y tiene
sus personas que van a defenderlo a él
en el ámbito lo que le hemos pedido
todos es que se defienda que no escatime
esfuerzos en rebatir todas estas
acusaciones donde hasta ahora
lastimosamente no ha tenido la
posibilidad de defenderse entonces creo
que es importante eso efectivamente yo
fui nombrado ministro de hacienda en el
periodo que él fue presidente de la
república me ha dado un tremendo apoyo
pero cada uno hemos tenido la
responsabilidad forjar nuestro propio
camino y así lo he hecho yo como
director del Banco Central como ministro
de hacienda ya como candidato hace cinco
años y hoy nuevamente ya a unos días de
ser electo presidente de la república el
apoyo político es fundamental verdad
Pero finalmente cada uno somos nuestra
propia persona y vamos a tener que
rendir cuentas por nuestros propios
actos Así que no tengo ninguna duda que
la formación académica que he obtenido
la experiencia en el ejercicio de la
función pública con una gestión que es
incuestionable en términos de honestidad
idoneidad y Patriotismo son mi carta de
presentación Más allá de cualquier apoyo
político que pudo haber tenido según
datos de la coordinadora de derechos
humanos de Paraguay el crimen organizado
se estaría infiltrando en todo el país
Incluso en algunos políticos cuáles son
sus planes para enfrentar el crimen
organizado lucha implacable contra la
corrupción la impunidad trabajar con los
administradores de la justicia el
Ministerio Público la Corte Suprema de
Justicia darle los recursos porque la
responsabilidad del Estado verdad recae
mayo en el poder ejecutivo que tiene que
generar los ingresos tiene que
administrar el estado y tiene que dar
los recursos necesarios para que la
justicia pueda hacer su trabajo una
justicia que sea pronta eficiente Así
que voy a trabajar incansablemente Creo
que lo que hemos construido a lo largo
de los últimos años más todo lo que
sabemos que podemos hacer nos va a
permitir enfrentar ese gran flagelo que
es un flagelo enorme a nivel mundial
continental y ahí también fortalecer los
vínculos con nuestros vecinos Brasil
Argentina y otros países de la región
donde sabemos que los delitos
transnacionales muchas veces tienen más
recursos que el propio estado y esto
tenemos que enfrentarlo de manera
también coordinada ante todos los países
si te vasos vecinos Yo le quería
preguntar una parte de la agrogranadería
está pidiendo que se recuperen las
relaciones comerciales con China y
sabemos que actualmente Paraguay tiene
una relación privilegiada con Taiwán si
usted llega al gobierno Cuál va a ser su
opción
hay que separar nosotros no tenemos
ninguna restricción de relaciones
comerciales con china continental de
hecho nuestro principal socio de donde
compramos productos es china nosotros
exportamos a China o sea nosotros
tenemos un comercio muy fluido sin
ningún tipo de restricciones pero
mantenemos una relación diplomática con
Taiwán hace más de 60 años una relación
que está forjada por no solamente una
historia y un vínculo afectivo sino
también sobre principios y valores
democráticos donde nosotros creemos de
que la experiencia de Taiwán también
puede ser muy favorable para Paraguay
como para un país pequeño que necesita
insertarse en el mundo el Paraguay es
todavía una economía dominada por el
sector agropecuario la ganadería la
agricultura y necesitamos acelerar un
proceso de industrialización y creemos
que un modelo como el taiwanés nos va a
ayudar a acelerar ese proceso de
industrialización versus un comercio con
china continental que es un país de mil
cuatrocientos millones miles de millones
de habitantes pueden ser muchos
consumidores pero también son grandes
productores de productos manufacturados
que pueden llevar a la economía
paraguaya hacer todavía más primaria de
lo que es hoy actualmente es de Paraguay
necesita fortalecer su vínculo
productivo su músculo productivo antes
de pensar de romper una relación que
realmente ha sido muy fructífera para el
Paraguay me pregunto si llega la
situación entre taguana China
complicarse Paraguay se va a posicionar
con China o con Taiwán con Taiwán en mi
gobierno con Taiwán no no hay ninguna
duda de eso Por supuesto no podemos
negar hay presión o sea hay una presión
enorme a nivel internacional de que
Paraguay rompa verdad Pero creo que la
historia del Paraguay desde su fundación
hace más de 200 años su lucha por el
territorio recuerde que fuimos a dos
Guerras en una perdimos 60 por ciento
del territorio y fuimos invadidos por
nuestros vecinos y donde perdimos el 90%
de la población masculina o sea Este es
un país que fue forjado por un gran
esfuerzo de paraguayo y nosotros no
podríamos ser menos es lo que nos lleva
a nosotros a pensar de que no porque un
país sea más grande tiene derecho a
invadir otro país o dominar otro país
hablando en relaciones diplomáticas cómo
piensa que va a ser su relación con los
Estados Unidos que han declarado al
Señor cartes significativamente corrupto
entiendo que usted no Descartes
obviamente pero esto puede influir de
alguna forma y no influyó hoy en la
relación entre el gobierno actual donde
también designaban al actual
vicepresidente de la República en
ejercicio creo que nuestros vínculos
afectivos económicos también de
principios y valores democráticos es muy
profundo Y eso no va a cambiar por una
decisión unilateral donde Estados Unidos
tiene todo su derecho a tomar estas
decisiones entonces creo que hay que
separar de lo que es una relación
bilateral histórica que ha sido
tremendamente positiva dados oficiales
muestran que hay cerca de un 30% de
pobreza en
con un 4% de pobreza extrema y al mismo
tiempo una gran desigualdad porque
incluso Paraguay es el país que más va a
crecer este año de la región Qué se
puede hacer para enfrentar la pobreza y
sobre todo es un problema que se puede
superar o es un problema endémico que no
tiene solución y se va a solucionar se
puede solucionar Y es inaceptable que en
un país tan rico como el Paraguay que
pueda alimentar a 80 millones de
personas en el mundo tengamos personas
que no pueden completar una ración
mínima de alimentos entonces De dónde
viene el gran problema principalmente de
las políticas públicas que han mejorado
nosotros tenemos redes de protección
social que no tienen 20 años o sea en
realidad la cobertura de esa red de
protección social se ha iniciado en las
últimas dos décadas ha mejorado de hecho
los números así lo dicen la pobreza ha
disminuido a la mitad del 50 por ciento
que en el año 2003 a 24 la pandemia
obviamente hizo aumentar en los últimos
año aumentó la pobreza en el Paraguay
pero estamos convencidos de nosotros
podemos llevar los niveles de pobreza a
niveles mínimos en comparación a todos
los países de América Latina Qué se
necesita para eso fortalecer la red de
protección social herramientas como las
transferencias condicionadas a familias
en situación de pobreza extrema el
acceso a la vivienda el acceso a
herramientas productivas que le permitan
trabajar el acceso a la tierra es un
elemento central así como queremos
defender la propiedad privada También
queremos promover el acceso a la
propiedad privada pero finalmente lo que
va a permitir no solamente salir de la
pobreza sino entrar en lo que es la
clase media la clase alta con niveles de
calidad de vida muy superior es la el
capital humano y ahí entra nuevamente lo
que te había hablado al comienzo
trabajar sobre la salud y la educación
señor Peña el domingo estuvimos en la
plaza Italia en una feria que
reivindicaba la liberalización de la
marihuana para usos recreativos Me
gustaría saber cuál es su opinión al
respecto y también sobre el debate de
Los pequeños productores creo que le
cuesta mucho al Estado
poder controlar estos mercados y es la
experiencia que estamos viendo de
Uruguay Uruguay con mucha noticia y
muchos titulares liberalizó el uso de la
marihuana para fines recreativos pero
finalmente lo olivan la ley ni no en la
práctica todavía sigue siendo un mercado
muy pequeño donde al estado le cuesta
mucho poder controlar y regular esto así
que creo que mientras no haya una visión
global de esto creo que Paraguay tiene
un problema hoy Paraguay es un gran
productor de marihuana donde tiene unas
tierras muy fértiles y la diferencia
entre el retorno económico de producir
marihuana y producir otro tipo de
cultivo es tremendo Entonces tenemos que
luchar contra eso y el otro problema es
el problema del tráfico verdad de la
cocaína que ingresa desde el norte y que
va después a otros países que inclusive
a Europa entonces Paraguay necesita
fortalecer sus organismos de control y
creo que tenemos que trabajar todavía en
esa línea antes de pensar en la
posibilidad que se pueda ver una
liberación de la producción y del
consumo y también tiene que ser un
esfuerzo colectivo entre todos los
países eso no va a poder ser algunos
países a una velocidad y otros países
que la hacían criminalizando finalmente
la ONU se ha mostrado en varias
ocasiones preocupada con el aumento de
embarazos indeseados y precoces entre
niñas y adolescentes de 10 a 19 años
cómo se posiciona usted sobre el tema
del aborto defensa de la vida de la
concepción y restricto está en la
Constitución yo fui padre a los 17 años
a los 17 años con mi actual señora nos
enteramos que íbamos a ser padre y jamás
fue una opción discontinuar un embarazo
Así que creo que no solamente está el
testimonio personal de uno la creencia
también los principios y valores
cristianos y también el respeto a lo que
es la constitución nacional la
Constitución Nacional del 92 es la que
cuida la vida de su Concepción y eso se
irá haciendo así los próximos cinco años
si yo soy electo presidente señor Peña
Muchísimas gracias por esa entrevista
exclusiva y gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos hasta aquí les invitamos a
que sigan nuestra programación en France
24 y France 24.com